every time you create a new business you
got to struggle a little bit and it
takes a while to build a brand it takes
about five years to be consistent
failing is never failing it's always a
learning experience it takes
fearlessness to be first you know to not
move with a crowd to move along
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn from
entrepreneur and music producer Damon
Dash and my take on his top ten rules
for success volume two rule number one
is my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
and as always guys as you're watching if
you hear something that really really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
how do you stay motivated not get burned
out I only do what I love you got to do
what you love you can't get burnt out
and I do get burnt out
you know once I'm in a business and I
don't enjoy it no more that's the thing
I can't it's hard for me to stay in the
business for a long period of time
because the people tend to make me sick
so as soon as I start to get aggravated
you know it's like I'll be on the block
if the block starts to make me mad I go
to another block I even if I got the
block click and it's just like I won't
compromise my quality of living you know
I'm saying but like right now what I'm
doing is you know I'm building things
that I could pass to my kids but only
things that I love them and my family so
I love making movies I'll make it movies
I love it I don't think I'm gonna be
burnt out with that anytime soon you
know and then also when you're in the
business of making money of other people
that person could make you sick and you
don't want to make money off them no
more so that's the reason why I try to
only make money off myself these days
and also do things that you know my girl
and my wife rocky because she's inspired
and will do that business I'm like
revolving my children I like that
business but I worked hard to put myself
in that position was there some pivotal
moment for you in your life where you
just really got it and and something
happened a fire ignited inside you that
made it so that you had all the moving
parts to make this amazing career unfold
I think the death of my mother probably
got me really focused and I understood
that there wasn't gonna be anyone there
to take care of me I did take care of
myself and just out of respect for her
life and all the things she did to make
me a better person I had to apply all
those things so you know at like 17 my
mother died when I was 16 and 17 you
know I was running the streets so heavy
and it was getting so critical that I
put myself in boarding school you know I
figured out how to get a scholarship and
because of the ability that my mother
gave me to articulate what's on my mind
to read to write you know cannot be
afraid and also I was you know boxing so
I got went to the boys club and they
were giving out scholarship for you know
he took a test I passed the test and you
know I made it and I was just always
able to put myself in a better place I
never let anybody else control my
destiny my mom's taught me to make
things happen on my own not to depend on
anybody and if I have an opinion to
speak on it the only way to
a professional is to work harder than
everybody a professional like a
professional baseball player boxes
someone that's better than everyone else
that's why he gets paid so much to do it
that means work it ain't nothing
professional going to give in to you
there's some sacrifice there's always
pain and you know it's always gonna be
dark times because that's part of
business every time you create a new
business you got to struggle a little
bit and it takes a while to build a
brand it takes about five years to be
consistent like my first five years you
know I'm not saying nothing different
I've been saying the same exact stuff if
you go look at um backstage and any kind
of argument I had it's always been
consistent it's just people weren't
ready for it they didn't trust it but
after I've been saying it for 10 years a
five you know five to ten now it's a
brand I have a brand foot I'm consistent
I back it up I'm still here I'm still up
even when you know being an independent
man looking like you was down failing is
never failing it's always a learning
experience soldier the thing about
business is how deep your pocket is I
always say that like if you got a lot of
money you could sustain these losses
until they turn into gains but if you
have a short paper if your money's not
long or if you don't have enough you
have to make sure that those losses
don't kill and compromise your pocket
and that's the point you got to get
creative
but when you do anything you get better
at it the more you do it and the first
time you do anything you usually don't
do it correct so it's not failure it's
learning experience if you could get up
and it's like in a fight the first round
you might get knocked out but by the
last round you get up and knock that
person now one don't you might lost
around but you win the whole fight what
you got to lose some rounds in business
but at the end of the day you want
unanimous decision you got to keep going
you got to finish the fight the question
is do you have the stamina to finish but
you get on the web and you did check out
fuse Dame - and there's so much crap how
do you deal with that and how do you
suggest other people deal with it when
they reach a certain level of celebrity
I mean when you sign on to being a
certain level of celebrity you got to
know they're gonna say things and you
know things are going to get eyeballs
and get people to buy you know sin and
you know I just I really don't care and
one of the reasons why I think I've been
successful is because I didn't care if I
cared I probably would be too scared to
promote people that people don't want to
promote you know it takes fearlessness
to be first you know to not move with a
crowd to move alone you know and you get
scrutinized by people that do move with
a crowd because they got
you look bad to make themselves look
good it's all part of the game it's like
a guy that's in high school that gets
all the girls the rest of the dudes hate
him in high school
so my whole life has been being that guy
in high school that everyone hates cuz I
keep taking their girls I can understand
that it's not a bad life so that's how I
look at it but the price of success is
unsuccessful people don't like you who
cares for us successful people don't
care about what another person is doing
because that's what people want
everybody else to be ceases to exactly
that's mine oh that's this whole mindset
that people don't understand right so
it's usually a bunch of unsuccessful
bitter bitter people and you know I was
a guy in school that you know was got
kicked out of every school I was the
class clown you know I wasn't the guy
that you would traditionally think would
be go this far so me making it made all
my teachers look stupid every principal
that kicked me out of school looks
stupid
you know I went to South Kent in
Connecticut on scholarship I didn't come
back the next year the next time I came
back was on the helicopter and I landed
it on the soccer field you know that
when I got kicked out of Dwight in the
seventh grade you know my son came back
and they were asking me you know I put
my son through the I paid full tuition
plus extras for tutoring and they asked
me to build a library I'm like the same
principal that kicked me out is asking
me to build a library so it's egg on all
their faces you know my success makes a
lot of people look like they were wrong
because a lot of people articulated the
fact that I wouldn't be what I am today
and either way either way I didn't care
but I think it's kind of funny it's egg
all over they face scramble is in
everyone but not everyone has a
discipline for anyone could be an
entrepreneur but not everyone wants to
be an
some people rather depend on other
people because they feel like they want
the work is hard but beyond the preneur
means working hard
it means embracing struggle it means
being a leader and never sending
somebody to do something that you
wouldn't do yourself a real boss will
never send somebody to do something when
you do themselves a boss that tell
somebody to do something the thing we do
is not a boss he's a cow and I that both
principals came to me from the people I
knew in this treaty right so I just want
to do so much that every dollar goes
back into the street like I just paid my
bills and if I wanna buy some I buy it
but you know I'm generally trying to
independently financed all my all the
things that inspired without compromise
so every time I pay for like I already
know I'm not holding no money like I
already know how I'm spending my first
billion I'm about a football team you
know saying like I have no intention on
holding any money and the only way to
get to a billion is to keep putting
money back into the companies and flip
it and I'm gonna just be flipping my
whole life you know that's just my game
malls I got cash flow I'm cool you know
I don't really believe a hole and no
money I think that's for suckers it's
hard you do a lot and it's all relative
you know what I mean like the first time
I heard a record on the radio I was
excited the first time I saw my video on
television I was excited the first time
I saw a movie at a theatrical level it
was very exciting
you know first times of anything are
exciting and I tend to have a lot of
first times you know what I'm saying
yeah that's absolutely incredible so I
try to recreate that first time feeling
by doing new things you know traveling
the world is important opening up art
galleries all over the world has been
fun you know opened up an art gallery in
Hong Kong was dope as well as Charleston
as well as the Lower East Side as well
as Tribeca
all of those first times were great you
know I'm saying being a different
neighborhood moving and not being scared
to you know have growing pains and
thanks to that nature so it's all been
really fun it's been a blast business
plan
about a business that doesn't exist is a
lie because you can't you can't say like
what are your facts based on because it
hasn't happened yet you can't really
determine who's going by what and how
much this cost sell you can't say I'm
gonna make a million this year doesn't
mean your ass you know what what I'll do
was put together without it's like a
script I'll put together how we make the
goods I'm gonna market the goods
how much is to buy the goods we have
with my margin and then when I'm gonna
sell it and then how much I'm gonna put
back into the business and I'm like I'm
gonna put it in my pocket
you know if that kind of thing you know
I write things that like if you look
look one put that on the wall right
there right you see you see a piece of
paper well I don't want it that's it I
got to do you know I like to put things
on the wall I can't even know what I've
got to do I need to look at it and
across it up I don't consider that a
business plan per se or but I have a
plan
you know I'm saying like I have a plan
plus you want other people to understand
the plan because you can't do anything
on your own so you want to be able to
articulate it to them away they
understand and that they can look back
at because I've talked quick and like
you said a lot of times I say [ __ ] you
like I didn't understand
tell me it'll tell you later you know so
you want to have something someone can
keep looking at and they can see you
crossing it off and then they can kind
of get it by absorbing fault you know by
watching what you're doing you know I
support the arts and I give people
platforms you know what I'm saying like
to me a real person that it is it's
supposed to be a leader is supposed to
serve the people you know what I'm
saying
that's what you're supposed to do you're
not supposed to be worried about
yourself you know what I was I've been
thinking about lately you notice that in
the music business traditionally it's
the businessman that's robbing the
artists and they always the artist ends
up with the with the behind the stories
the way they now I would add now nobody
my artist that I ever touch a rich ain't
doing well and I'm the one that's always
looking for a wild doesn't that way it
is because I give it all the way I'm not
trying to take the artist have him in my
pocket for his life and jerk him and
have him resent me you know I'm saying
I'm ready to get him out my pocket be
like look man go win go eat go be
yourself we'd leave me alone
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jose Cruz asked
me to if there's something you'd like me
to cover in a future top 10 check out
the link in the description and go and
cast your vote I'd also love to know
what did you learn from this video what
lesson really hit home the hardest what
are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Melissa
Alexandria Melissa thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing the review and posting it
to your channel I really really
appreciate your support and I'm so glad
that you enjoyed the read thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
you know one thing you have to really
never do is compare yourself to other
people absolutely that's the one thing
you can't do is judge the success to
someone else's a lot of people the one
that's with social media does man the
people man looking at people's pages and
you like that good and I just couldn't
support if you're insecure yes if you're
insecure social media could destroy you
there's a lot of people that think that
the only way you can make it especially
in our business the entertainment
industry that you know you can't be an
honorable honest hard-working person
you've got to be willing to do whatever
it takes regardless of how you
compromise your own ethics to get to
wherever it is you want to get and I've
never believed that and it doesn't sound
like you believe it either
no you know I don't consider that a win
I consider that cheating and I can't
live with myself if I don't play the
game right but other people don't like
you go into different cultures and
especially in business it's like yo you
got to win any way you can if somebody's
slipping and you don't take advantage of
it you're dishonouring your family like
I've been in cultures like that mmm-hmm
you know we're lying is okay for your
business you know you're supposed to do
that or else you're a sucker so you know
it's just a matter of perspective and
the cloth you're cut from and you know
it's a rougher world when everyone is
cheating and you're playing the game
right you know it's a tough world but at
the end of the day it's worth it because
you know there's nothing more valuable
than your soul your integrity your
freedom you know just being proud of
yourself I just don't feel like you know
when you you can't call yourself a
winner if you're cheating you know
you're cheating you know that's just how
I feel and you might not get caught in
the human form but God will get you
anything - got or whatever the supreme
being is but a go-getter or when you're
telling somebody to eat the food they
kill it that's the same thing as saying
you got to put up your own money like a
lot of people would be like oh I need a
check another saying I need it I have to
pay my bills so they won't take any
chances they'll do minimal actually
they'll try to escape work they'll live
for Friday just so they could just pay
those bills or being dead but when you
tell somebody to eat the food they kill
they got to go out there they got to
work they got
and if they don't make money they don't
pay their bills but to me it's an option
I'm gonna make my brave yeah the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
that sums you Apple so it would be like
a little beacon pay believe nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and
Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]